AMADIO.
>> Craig: THEY IT FOR WASHING
LONG WRISTER FROM THEODORE.
DEFLECTED AWAY.
>> CHECK.
CENTERING BID TUCKED AWAY BY
CARLSON AND BACK COMES
WASHININ THE
OUTSIDE.
LARS ELLERS THERE LOST IT.
STICK CHECK  CENTERING PASS TO
McMICHAEL.
ALL CARES INITIATIVE.
THOSE TEDDY BEARS AND STUFF
ANIMALS BEING DONATED TO LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
IT'S SO MUCH FUN.
>> Craig: AND I T TCraig:DOWN
FLORIDA AS DADNOV. STEPHENSON,
BLOCK.
PIETRANGELO DRIVE.
A STICK CHECK TOWASHINGTON 6-5.S
WE HEAR THE WHISTLE, SPACE OFF
STAYNG DOG FOOD DURING THE
PREGAME SHOW.
MY LITTLE FRIEND PUPPY CAMOF
WOOD ON
LOTS OF REALLY GOOD WASHINGTON.
NEITHER TEAM HAS TURNED ON THE
RED LIGHT INSIDE OF CAPITAL  THE
THE BENCH.
CARLSON DONE.
>>
KUZNETSOV SEES MORE AND MORE
FIRES AT THE HEAVY DUTY WRISTER
THAT WENT HIGH.
>> FROM ROY.
NIC ROY FINDS THE WALL.
MARCHESSAULT FIRES.
HERE'SIT
CARRIER.
>> Craig:A PIECE.
AMADIO HASRLOV'S LOAN PP SCORED
IN RALEIGH.
PROVED TO  KNIGHTS WAY TWO CROSS
BARS.
THIS ONE ON THE LAST SEQUENCE.
JUST GETTING THE
SHEARY.
>> Craig: WHAT'S THE OLD
CLICHE.
A GAMECHIP IT IN.
>> Craig: PIETRANGELO
e: TO CARRIER ON
DUMP IN AT THE DRAW.
>> Craig: CARLSON GETS EN ALL
BETWEEN THESE TROUBLE.
>> Craig: THEY'RE STARTING TO
HOLD THE